wholly counted I learned a ton from this
book
to tell me that had you read this book
earlier you would now be president
well I would be more powerful than I am
now uh categorically I can't believe
that but you open the book by talking
about the resistance you get toward
trying to teach someone about power that
it somehow seems dirty nasty
objectionable I don't want to know I
don't want to learn and yet this is the
most popular over subscribed course in
Stanford so I think now everyone feels
like they have to know and you give a
great argument for why it's like look I
don't care about uh what your
motivations are this is still stuff that
you you should learn
um so what what is the argument you make
to the people who think like power like
my even wanting power makes me a bad
person well I think you put your finger
on on why many people object to this
they have seen power used for bad
they've seen bad people use power to do
bad things and so they say I don't want
anything to do with it so it's like you
know if you saw somebody shoot somebody
with a gun you would say well I won't I
don't want anything to do with guns even
though you can use guns for target
practice or hunting or you know for
recreation for all kinds of things and
so I think people confuse how power has
been used
um with with the necessity for power in
order to get things done so Stanford
Business Schools motto changed lives
change organizations change the world as
you know from your own from your own
experience both in business and in
politics if things were going to change
without influence they would have
already so therefore so therefore if you
are going to make the for instance the
kinds of reforms in the electoral system
that you're interested in or there or
the car or if you want to try to somehow
get people to have guaranteed basic
income or if you're going to get
anything done you know clean up the
climate or do whatever you want to do
it's going to require influence and
power because that's the necessity of
social life the things that you detail
about trying to create a personal
powerful brand I went I'd gone through
many of them which were things around a
Blog conference speaking uh writing a
book if that's applicable a lot of
behaviors that end up marking you as an
expert in some way yep and
is to tie what you are doing or trying
to do or the job for which you're
applying tying that to something about
your background so so I you know a good
example with my friend Tristan Walker
Walker and Company brands which was
bought by Procter Gamble Tristan is a
African-American man
who always had trouble
shaving because of the
African-American skin is different and
he would get razor bumps and so double
edged razors didn't work very well and
when he went finally into various drug
stores and and stores he saw that there
was very few of them that had been
designed for people of color either for
men or for women and so what the whole
theory behind Walker and Company brands
was here with someone a Stanford MBA
graduate by the way uh here was someone
who was designing products
for himself
and the people that he knew the people
in his community and and that made him
you know when I talked to Jeff Jordan
the founder of Open Table it was at that
time working friend Andreessen Horowitz
he said we like to fund people who when
you look at them you say these people
are uniquely qualified to be to be
driving and building this kind of
company so who is better qualified to
build a company with grooming products
for people of color than someone of
color you know who is better qualified
as also interesting because Tristan
comes to my class and there was an
African-American student who had not by
the way said very much in the class and
we decided to randomly call on him and
he said to you know describe your brand
and he described his brand very
succinctly he had come from a very poor
neighborhood in which there were
enormous Health inequalities and health
adverse Health consequences and he said
you know he said I went to medical
school school because I'm a black man
and I want to bring Medical
help I want to bring Medical Care to to
the black community what a powerful
brand a sentence or two which explains
why he's not only that he's gone to
fancy medical schools which he has and
he's now in Sanford business school
which he was but why he was doing this
how he could tie what his mission was to
his own life experience
thank you
[Music]